>> WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO OUR
JOB AND GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THESE ACCUSATIONS TO FIND OUT IF
THEY ARE TRUE.
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, HANDING OUT
LIKE IT WAS CANDY OR WHETHER IT
WAS INTOXICATION OR A TOXIC WORK
ENVIRONMENT.
>> HE DESERVES HIS DAY IN COURT.
I ASSUME THE COMMITTEE WILL GIVE
HIM THAT.
IT'S TROUBLING TO A LOT OF US.
>> DR. JACKSON HAS HAD AT LEAST
FOUR INDEPENDENT BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATIONS CONDUCTED DURING
HIS TIME AT THE WHITE HOUSE
INCLUDING AN FBI INVESTIGATION
CONDUCTED AS PART OF THE
STANDARD NOMINATION VETTING
PROCESS.
DURING EACH OF THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS, DR. JACKSON
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS PRAISE FROM
DOZENS OF WITNESSES, AND THE
INVESTIGATIONS REVEALED NO AREAS
OF CONCERN.
>> Bret: AS OF TONIGHT, RONNY
JACKSON IS STILL THE NOMINEE FOR
VETERANS AFFAIRS SECRETARY, AND
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS SAYING TO
GET A CONFIRMATION PROCESS
STARTED AGAIN ON CAPITOL HILL.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
CHARLES HURT, OPINION WRITER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
MO ELLEITHEE, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE GEORGETOWN INSTITUTE OF
POLITICS.
JONATHAN SWAN, NATIONAL
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR AXIOS.
JONATHAN, IS THE WHITE HOUSE
FIRM IN THE PUSHBACK, SEEMS SO.
BEHIND THE SCENES, ARE THEY
SAYING THE SAME THING?
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS CONFLICTED
IN THE SENSE THAT THEY ALMOST
UNANIMOUSLY, I HAVE YET TO FIND
ANYONE WHO DOESN'T THINK HE'S A
GOOD MAN WHO IS BEING UNFAIRLY
-- ALLEGATIONS ARE OUT THERE.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE TRUE
OR NOT.
SOME OF THEM HAVE BECOME
PERSONALLY, THOSE CLOSE TO HIM
FEEL UPSET TO SEE THIS HAPPENING
TO A GUY THEY CONSIDER TO BE A
GOOD MAN.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, IT'S VERY
HARD TO FIND A SENIOR
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL WHO THINKS
THAT HE'S THE RIGHT SELECTION
FOR THE JOB.
AND BELIEFS TRUMP UNANNOUNCED
HIM IN THE CORRECT WAY.
TRUMP TWEETED IT OUT WITHOUT ANY
VETTING OVER JOHN KELLY'S
OBJECTIONS AND ALMOST NO ONE IN
SENIOR STAFF THAT THAT WAS A
GOOD IDEA.
>> Bret: SARAH'S POINT IS THAT
HE HAD BEEN VETTED FOR HIS JOB
AS PHYSICIAN TO THE PRESIDENT.
VERY CLOSELY.
THE FBI CHECKS AND ALL THAT
STUFF.
>> DOCTOR TO THE PRESIDENT IS
QUITE DIFFERENT FROM RUNNING THE
SECOND LARGEST AGENCY AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
HE HAS NO MANAGEMENT EXPERIENCE
THAT WOULD BE RELEVANT FOR THAT
JOB.
THAT'S THEIR CONCERN.
I THINK THIS IS ALL NEW
INFORMATION FOR THEM AND THEY
ARE ABSORBING IT.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO MAKE OF
IT.
FOR THE MOMENT, THEY ARE ON A
FLAT FOOT.
>> Bret: TWO DIFFERENT SIDES.
ONE IS THAT THE WHITE HOUSE PUTS
SOMEONE OUT THAT PERHAPS, WITH
THE ALLEGATIONS BACK THERE AND
THEY KNOW ABOUT ITS END AND IT
COMES OUT.
THE OTHER SIDE'S DEMOCRATS IN
THE MINORITY PUT OUT THE PRESS
THESE ALLEGATIONS THAT PUBLICLY
SAY THEY DON'T KNOW ARE TRUE.
THE MINORITY SAYING MULTIPLE
INDIVIDUALS CITING THE NICKNAME
CANDYMAN USED BY THE WHITE HOUSE
STAFF BECAUSE HE WOULD PROVIDE
WHATEVER PRESCRIPTIONS THEY
SOUGHT WITHOUT PAPERWORK.
DESCRIBING HANDING OUT AMBIEN TO
SLEEP.
WITHOUT TRIAGING PATIENT
HISTORY.
NO INTAKES, NO QUESTIONNAIRES.
I CAN TELL YOU PERSONALLY I WAS
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT.
I TOOK AMBIEN FROM DOCTORS ON
TRIPS OVERSEAS.
THESE ARE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
THAT REQUIRE TRACKING.
ON ONE OCCASION DR. JACKSON
COULD NOT BE REACHED WHEN NEEDED
BECAUSE HE WAS PASSED OUT DRUNK.
AT A SECRET SERVICE PARTY,
JACKSON GOT DRUNK AND WRECKED A
VEHICLE.
JACKSON DENIES THOSE THINGS
VEHEMENTLY.
AS FAR AS THE PASSING OUT OF
AMBIEN, UNLESS IT'S SOMETHING
BIGGER OR MORE SERIOUS AS FAR AS
THE DRUGS, THAT HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME.
>> YOU RAISED TWO GOOD
QUESTIONS, RIGHT?
DEMOCRATS COULD HAVE BROUGHT
THIS UP IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
A PRODUCT TO THE WHITE HOUSE,
SAID THIS IS WHAT WE ARE SEEING
AND WE ARE GOING TO ASK ABOUT
THIS IN A HEARING.
THEY COULD HAVE DONE THAT.
THE SECOND ISSUE WOULDN'T HAPPEN
TO HAVE THE FIRST ONE NOT HAPPEN
FIRST.
THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT DID
NOT VET, THE WHITE HOUSE DID NOT
VET HIM OR THEY WOULD'VE CAUGHT
THAT THERE WERE 20 ALLEGATIONS.
CAUGHT IT AND PREPPED FOR IT AND
THEY WOULD'VE ADDRESSED IT ON
THE FRONT-END.
IT FITS A NARRATIVE AND A TRACK
RECORD OF THIS WHITE HOUSE OF
BEING LESS THAN CAREFUL WITH
VETTING.
I DON'T THINK EITHER SIDE PUT
ITS BEST FOOT FORWARD BUT I
THINK THE WHITE HOUSE CERTAINLY
CAUSED THIS PROBLEM BY NOT DOING
BASIC VETTING.
>> Bret: WHICH WAS MY POINT IN
SAYING, CHARLIE, BOTH SIDES
COULD DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
THE DEMOCRATS COULD HAVE REACHED
OUT AND SAID THIS IS WHAT WE ARE
HEARING.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT IT OR
LET'S MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
HEARING IF YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
IT.
>> IF ALL THESE ALLEGATIONS OR
ANY OF THE ALLEGATIONS ARE TRUE,
IT SORT OF REFLECTS MORE POORLY
OVER TIME ON THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION THAT IT DOES ON
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION THAT
ALL OF THESE TERRIBLE THINGS
WERE GOING ON INSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE ON FOREIGN TRIPS.
UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT SAID, THE PRESIDENT DOES
HAVE A HABIT OF CROSSING THE
STREET WITHOUT LOOKING BOTH
WAYS.
BUT IT WORKS FOR HIM.
AND I THINK THE ACCUSATIONS THAT
THIS GUY IS NOT QUALIFIED TO RUN
SUCH A LARGE, COMPLEX
ORGANIZATION.
MY GOODNESS, WHO IS?
THE PREVIOUS PERSON IN THAT SPOT
HAD A LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH
MANAGEMENT AND HE WAS A
DISASTER.
THAT GOES TO THE NATURE, IF YOU
ASK ME COME OUT OF THE WHOLE
PROBLEM OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TODAY.
WE HAVE THESE AGENCIES THAT ARE
COMPLETELY UNGOVERNABLE.
>> THAT'S THE CONVERSATION I
THINK A CONFIRMATION HEARING
SHOULD BE ABOUT, RIGHT?
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE, AT LEAST
FOR NOW, BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE STUDENT
ABOUT THE GUY AND THESE OTHER
ALLEGATIONS ARE POPPING UP.
IT GOES TO YOUR POINT, RIGHT,
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING BOTH WAYS
THEY ARE CREATING --
>> Bret: THIS IS NOT ACCURATE.
LET'S LISTEN TO SENATOR TESTER,
ANOTHER SOUND BITE IN HIS
INTERVIEW WHERE HE IS LAYING OUT
THESE ALLEGATIONS.
>> HE HANDS OUT PRESCRIPTIONS
LIKE CANDY.
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, THEY CALL
HIM THE CANDYMAN.
COMMENTS ABOUT HIM BEING IN THE
HOTEL ROOM AND COULDN'T RESPOND
BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN DRINKING SO
MUCH.
THE STUFF HAPPENED MOSTLY DURING
THE EIGHT YEARS OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
I DON'T THINK PRESIDENT OBAMA
WAS AWARE OF THE STUFF OR HE
WOULDN'T HAVE TOLERATED IT IF IT
WAS TRUE.
>> Bret: SO WHICH ONE IS THAT,
THEY CALL HIM THE CANDYMAN?
OCTOBER 2016, THE PRESIDENT
WRITES "RONNIE DOES A GREAT JOB,
GENUINE ENTHUSIASM, POISE UNDER
PRESSURE, INCREDIBLE WORK ETHIC.
RONNIE CONTINUES TO INSPIRE
CONFIDENCE.
CONTINUE TO PROMOTE AHEAD OF
PEERS.
WHICH ONE IS IT?
EITHER THEY DON'T KNOW OR THEY
KNOW.
>> I DON'T USUALLY TRY TO GET
ANGRY ON TV BUT I ACTUALLY DO
FEEL A SENSE OF DEEP CONCERN AND
ANGER AT SOME OF THIS BECAUSE I
BROKE THAT STUPID STORY ON
SUNDAY.
THEY HAD DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT HIM
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, ON THE HILL.
HIS CONFIRMATION WERE      WAS I
HIS CONFIRMATION WERE      WAS N
HIS CONFIRMATION WERE      WAS P
HIS CONFIRMATION WERE      WAS R
HIS CONFIRMATION WERE      WAS L
HIS CONFIRMATION WERE      WAS .
THE REASON I WROTE IT THAT WAY
IS NOT BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT THE ALLEGATIONS WERE.
I KNEW WHAT THEY WERE.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE
TRUE.
I HAVE NO EARTHLY IDEA IF THEY
ARE TRUE OR NOT.
I'M NOT JUST GOING TO GO, IT'S
ALLEGED, AND I AM HEARING THAT
THIS GUY DID ALL OF THESE
TERRIBLE THINGS, X, Y, AND Z.
BECAUSE I HAVE NO IDEA IF IT'S
TRUE OR NOT.
CLEARLY NEITHER DOES JON TESTER.
IT'S A PROBLEM.
>> Bret: THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS
THEY CALLED HIM THE CANDYMAN BUT
MAY BE PRESIDENT OBAMA DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT IT BECAUSE HE WROTE
THESE GLOWING -- AT THE END OF
THE ADMINISTRATION.
THERE IS A DISCONNECT HERE.
CLEARLY THIS IS A GUY WHO HAS
A STERLING REPUTATION, A LOT AT
STAKE.
WE SAW THE SOMEWHAT HUMOROUS
RESPONSE FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHEN HE WAS ASKED ABOUT WHETHER
HE STOOD BEHIND RONNY JACKSON
AND HE SAID I DON'T KNOW IF I
WOULD GO FORWARD WITH IT IF I
WERE HIM.
IN WASHINGTON SPEAK, EVERYONE
WAS LIKE OH, HE IS NOT BACKING
RONNY JACKSON.
>> Bret: THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I
SAID.
>> BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP AND THE WAY HE
REACTS AND, HE DOESN'T SPEAK
WASHINGTON SPEAK.
HE WAS JUST TRYING TO SAY YOU
HAVE THIS GOOD GUY GETTING
DRAGGED THROUGH THE MUD.
HE LOOKS GREAT IN A UNIFORM.
I DON'T KNOW WHY -- AND THEN HE
HAD THAT MOMENT --
>> HE ALSO SAID IT'S GOING TO BE
UP TO RONNY JACKSON TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT THE CONFIRMATION
GOES FORWARD.
I AGREE WITH YOU, THE FIRST
MIGHT BE LIGHTHEARTED AND FUN
BUT THAT'S A PRETTY CLEAR THING
TO SAY ONLY RONNY JACKSON WILL
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT IT GOES
FORWARD.
THAT'S LESS OF A RINGING
ENDORSEMENT.
THAT'S THE PRESIDENT SAYING